it's a Friday PFT ot some topics to
supplement everything else that we
discussed earlier today on pro football
talk live a lot of ground covered with
big CAD you can see plenty of clips at
Pro Football Talk on full podcast
available as well wherever you can find
your podcast materials we didn't talk
about Antonio Brown though for the first
time in a long time
PFT live at least the two hours on NBCSN
included no a/b discussion and as of
right now we really don't know what to
expect from Antonio Brown on Sunday
starting with the question whether not
who even play now the Patriots are
sending out every indication that
Antonio Brown will play he practiced on
Wednesday practiced on Thursday but
hovering over all of this is the NFL's
obvious discomfort with a civil lawsuit
that was filed against Antonio Brown
earlier this week accusing him of sexual
assault and rape the NFL could place him
on the Commissioner exempt list based
upon the preliminary investigation of
that situation but they have yet to
speak to the accuser kind of awkward
kind of unusual to consider placing on
paid leave a guy who hasn't been
arrested hasn't been criminally charged
is facing a lawsuit and the person who
has made those accusations has never
even been spoken to face to face by the
National Football League so if the NFL
really doesn't want him to play I could
envision some sort of a backroom deal
where the NFL approaches the Patriots
and says can't you just like conclude
that he's not ready and wait a week and
then that buys the NFL time to do enough
of the investigation that they can
decide whether or not the the plaintiff
in the lawsuit the accuser of Antonio
Brown is telling a sufficiently
compelling story to get the NFL to put
him on the Commissioner exempt list but
this is a serious serious matter for the
NFL when they leaked to The Washington
Post earlier this week that they were
giving serious consideration to paid
leave for Antonio Brown that tells me
they're not comfortable with the man who
has co-opted season number 100 playing
right away in the aftermath of this
lawsuit because the bottom line is this
if he plays that's just more discussion
of something that is not a good look
the NFL and make no mistake about it the
entire personal conduct policy the
Commissioner exempt list the process for
disciplining players everything about it
is driven by PR in the NFL thinks it's a
bad look if they have guys who have
either committed certain types of
misconduct or simply been accused of
that misconduct running around on the
field being talked about and having
football fans aware of these situations
but you know what with the Antonio Brown
it's gonna be talked about whether or
not he plays on Sunday but if he goes
out and he has a big game it probably
will be an even greater focus of
discussion one guy who had a great game
week one for the Houston Texans DeAndre
Hopkins and he's got Jalen Ramsey coming
to town to face Houston in their home
open to the Jaguars Owen one the Texans
Owen one and DeAndre Hopkins said the
Jalen Ramsey the Jaguar is the only
cornerback who truly follows him
everywhere he goes you know that's a
point of pride for defensive backs
because the ones who do follow the top
receiver that the other team puts out on
the offense that that corner is the one
that basically says I'm the real guy I'm
the good one I'm the one that truly
plays the position because I always face
down the number one receiver well Ramsey
is that guy according to the Andre
Hopkins and Ramsey is gonna have his
hands full because Hopkins seemed on
Monday night like he's elevating his
game to another level now it won't
matter if deshaun Watson can't buy
enough time to throw the ball to DeAndre
Hopkins and that's really gonna be the
matchup to watch beyond Hopkins vs
Ramsey does Shawn Watson have enough
time is is that front line going to hold
up under the onslaught that is coming
from the Jacksonville Jaguars because I
think the front seven at the Jaguars
better than the front seven of the New
Orleans Saints and we saw what the
Saints did to the Texans on Monday night
one last topic before we wrap it up
today Phillip Rivers recently told Ian
Rapoport of the NFL that Rivers is at
peace with the fact that he is entering
and already in the final year of his
contract and look it's rare to see a
franchise quarterback in the last year
of his contract we thought Tom Brady was
going to be and then he got an extension
and then it turned out the extension
really means he's in the last year of
his contract so you know it's
not all that unusual for older
quarterback Drew Brees went through it
fairly recently the season ends and then
you decide what you're gonna do after
that and I think that's what the charge
would want to do it's what Phillip
Rivers wants to do but I think the
Chargers you know how did we forget that
job in the first place they had Drew
Brees they acquired Phillip Rivers in
that trade with the Giants for Eli
Manning and then a year or two later
out goes Drew Brees I don't think the
Chargers will hesitate to move on from
Phillip Rivers before Phillip Rivers is
ready to move on and we've heard some
rumors in recent years of quarterbacks
that the charges were considering and
III feel like there's a chance that at a
time when we are so focused on when
quarterbacks are gonna choose to walk
away from the teams they're with whether
it's Drew Brees whether spend
Roethlisberger whether it's Tom Brady
the charges could be the one team out of
that group that is and Eli Manning is
the guy who's gonna get shoved
eventually by the Giants so there'll be
two teams but the charge is gonna fall
onto that side of the equation where
they may end up saying Phillip we kind
of want to move on before Phillip is
ready to call it quits or leave for
another team and I can't imagine him
ever playing for another team but
crazier things have happened in the NFL
Joe Namath play for the Rams Johnny
Unitas played for the Chargers we know
what happened with Brett Favre we know
what happened with Peyton Manning and I
think of anything it's kind of unusual
that as we've gotten all these older
quarterbacks in the NFL now we haven't
had another situation like that where
you've got a very recognizable face and
name ending up in a new uniform so maybe
it will be Philip Rivers maybe it will
be Eli Manning we'll see but there's a
great cluster of guys on the wrong side
of 35 and it would be foolish to think
that not a single one of them is going
to end up finishing his career with
another team that's it for this week of
pft live and pft ot content we will be
posting stories all weekend long at Pro
Football Talk comm leading up to week
two we'll be with you all day long on
Sunday with story after story after
story at Pro Football Talk comm keeping
track of all the games Sunday Night
Football and then Monday morning back at
it with PFT
everybody have a great weekend we'll
talk to you soon
[Music]
you